under the international bridge in del
rio in texas a camp that's become home
to thousands and which reveals yet
another crisis at the border in america
they cross the rio grande river that
forms the border between the u.s and
mexico most of them haitians willing to
take the chance that they will be
processed and allowed in
willing to tolerate what's been
described as a squalid existence here
there is not enough food to give to
everybody who was inside there we need
to get out of the camp to look for food
things are worse
it is these pictures of border patrol
agents on horseback pushing migrants
into the river that have caused so much
anger for some they carry the echoes of
the worst chapters of american history
what we witness takes us back hundreds
of years
what we witnessed was worse than what we
witnessed in slavery
cowboys
with their reigns again
whipping
black people
haitians into the water
the u.s has already removed thousands
from the camp large numbers flown back
to haiti a country many of them left
after the earthquake a decade ago and
now consumed by violence and poverty
these chaotic scenes prompting the
resignation of the u.s special envoy
i will not be associated with the united
states inhumane counterproductive
decision to deport thousands of haitian
refugees daniel foote wrote to the
secretary of state our policy approach
to haiti remains deeply flawed and it is
a crisis the president has so far not
addressed
we could not see it as any more
different from the policy of the prior
administration which the president feels
we all feel was inhumane immoral
ineffective not operationally wasn't
operationally working
in texas the river crossings have been
stopped for now and the authorities say
the camp will be empty within days but
the flow of those trying to reach
america it seems can't be stopped the
only question is where and when this
will happen again
greg milam sky news